hello there reject nation I'm Greg
elbows now I'm John Humphrey you're
gonna watch Aldo Jones's video today
spider-man far from home weird trailer
numero dos second new parody that's a
long ass title gotta get those clicks
it's gotta get those clicks am i right
guys if you haven't pledged to Aldo
Jones's patreon page do it as soon as
you can we pledged 25 cents that's not
even possible but we figured out a way
to do it maybe you can't do let's get to
it
despite my too far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers endgame yet Tony starts dead
[Music]
pretty excited about you guys don't know
this channel sometimes I want to post
something shorter like stories but I
still don't want it to be severe after
few hours so I was pretty excited when I
found out about aminos news stories
we're on a me know - we work for them
funny asylum for is also other stuff
that we've come to my mind in the future
click the link in the description or
pinned YouTube comments or search for
any apps to download amino once you have
installed the app you can find my
stories in this way go in the search bar
setup users and inserts Aldo Jones make
sure to follow me and click the bell to
know when I'm posting your videos just
let YouTube every time you watch my
creations you'll be supporting me so if
you like my videos this is a sim so
happy for any way to keep me so happy
for you
I'm glad we're part of the same company
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's very aware of what's going on here
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes I picked the wrong day to wear my
new croc seize the snap to our home in
our dimension
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it looks good
oh you want to step
although there's a beautiful she played
the flute yo
wait a sponsor Anton I was wonderful
this is like a star studded patreon
episode of aldo jones right here so many
patrons who did so much love and
supports that's what we like to see oh
man we could be in one of these we just
supported out oh no
[Music]
ooh what's that well that's that
Aldo you're probably the most consistent
youtuber to have ever existed on the
face of this earth I'm so proud of you
gosh how far you've come we're watching
that BVS one way back in the day and now
look at you now are even showing your
face on camera just looking ridiculously
sexy you got the perfect hair you get
the perfect beard you got the perfect
voice the glasses man I don't even
remember any of this we're trailer four
members looking at your sexy face dude
and just hearing like a saxophone
soundtrack and like a lot of soft
lighting you want to spend an evening I
want to spend a romantic weekend without
Oh Jones you know just caressing each
other's beards and coming up with we
don't blame you yeah I don't blame you
job you know I'm speaking of your weird
trailer from the very beginning making
fun of that whole spoiler warning thing
cos Tom long was made fun of quite a bit
for doing that only because of the fact
that spoiler for like half these Marvel
yeah the joke was so well done you know
if you haven't seen it
Tony's orc is dead and then there's just
immediate trollface warp yeah
what's funny is they actually shot two
of those intros in case you guys don't
know like when I went to IMAX Universal
to watch end game they had Tom Holland
in the same setup but he said stay after
the movie to go watch the new trailer
for far from home because her spoilers
in it but then I heard reports that they
were accidentally playing that trailer
the spoiler filled one before certain
screenings of Avengers and game and they
really screwed that up so that joke
especially I quite enjoyed just a bit
and I'm gonna say that effects on the
missing eyes when he pulls down the
glasses pulls down the shades that looks
so real it's like eerie and creepy that
looks like looks like some type of weird
practical effect here I'm a little Toro
[ __ ] man that was mightily a Silent Hill
honestly ya know that's the right way to
put it or they kind of look like those
thumbs from Spy Kids I think there was a
lot of kind of creepy horror stuff that
seeped into I noticed a couple specific
earmarks about this weird trailer one of
them was yeah like the horror stuff cuz
you all set him on the plane I think
that's the movie version of The Twilight
Zone with the creature on the wing you
know nightmare 20,000 feet yeah got a
pretty good kick out of that but what I
also picked up on is like a lot more
like match cutting into other scenes and
stuff with this like during the fight
where they cut to the guy in the green
suit or even like super imposing like
here's pictures of the black suit
spider-man but you know taking that
scene from spider-man 3 and then
splicing in those shots like or even
with the darts before sheets Ned you got
a lot of sonic the hedghog references in
here yeah I feel like we're gonna be
getting a lot more from you the way how
bully McGuire sort of has taken off for
you I feel like you're probably gonna
use a lot more of the sonic stuff
especially until that movie finally
comes out nobody cares and when they
have the official redesign of Sonic the
Hedgehog or at least I think you're
gonna do a lot of fun stuff you're
moving both parody throwing them both in
there I think you're gonna have a total
blast of that so I had this thought of
like oh man well they have a new
redesign how those gonna go crazy
we're gonna go handedly keep creepy
sonic alive and that's the other thing
do you like going back to what you said
about watching Aldo's work grow over
time one thing that really rewarded me
for this as a fan of bully McGuire from
spider-man 3 was just like all of the
multiverse stuff that he decided to do
have different tobey's popping up and
then Andrew Garfield popping up and then
all the spider-verse characters at one
point well I remember I think it was the
last far from home weird trailer that we
covered saying how uh-oh I was a little
bummed out that you didn't include any
of spider-verse or any of the multiverse
characters in there and the fact that
you actually did it this time around
makes me very happy you have completely
satisfied me I really hope you get
around to doing some type of spider or
into the spider for spoof thing I know
that the movies already out on blu-ray
and stuff but if you could like do
something where you include a lot more
of those because that movies already so
hyper and so weird
yeah this is where I put my requests
down I don't put it on my 10 cent pledge
that I gave to your paper
I put it right here in the YouTube
videos hoping that you will eventually
just do the things I'm asking you to do
because if you were to toy around with
spider-verse that would get me super
excited man I feel like you could do
some really crazy weird [ __ ] to the
point where you're not even sure if it's
from spider-verse
or if it's something that you made up is
that weird it is from the mind of El
dojo
oh man I'd love to explore that hell of
a lot I want to see that on a big screen
someday just from the mind of al dojo
yes whatever that feature would be how
about - Laquisha trailer next man that's
our that's our next your next adventure
waiting for you it's calling your name
or at least put Laquisha in every
trailer somewhere as like an easter egg
from people all right guys well make
sure to subscribe to Aldo Jones's page
linked in the description box goes to
pledge to his patreon you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects if you
liked this video please hit that like
button click that notification bell
whatever else youtubers say
congratulations to Jake Paul I heard he
got engaged he's my favorite youtuber
love them see you guys